[Música]
escala en París Braulio Moro
bienvenidos escala en París de misión de
radio Francia internacional en
colaboración con la televisión France 24
en español en la que damos la palabra
artistas políticos gente de las ciencias
de las artes del mundo de la cultura y
de la sociedad civil el sur por
definición es uno de los puntos
cardinales igual puede ser una
referencia en el Horizonte otro lugar un
cuya posición se compara y el título de
un libro Sur la novela más reciente del
escritor español Antonio Soler objeto de
múltiples recompensas en España
publicado recientemente en su versión
francesa por ediciones Rivas Antonio
Soler Bienvenido a esta escala en París
Gracias por aceptar nuestra invitación
muchas gracias encantado de estar con
ustedes un placer tenerlo con nosotros
Sur es la más reciente de una prolongada
lista de novelas que usted ha escrito es
también la más que ha tenido más éxito
la más renombrada la más perfeccionada
Por qué eligió Este título
bueno
es curioso porque trabajé con con varios
títulos siempre siempre ocurre o casi
siempre y finalmente me pareció que era
algo que definía lo que yo quería hacer
es
una mirada sobre un Sur que normalmente
parece que es idílico desde los versos
de cuasimodo y todo esto pero que
también tiene una cara menos amable yo
creo que la literatura que de verdad
indaga en el ser humano no siempre es
complaciente y a veces nos sirve como un
espejo en el que El lector se descubre a
sí mismo y me parecía que el sur por el
título de Sur podían cerrar un poco de
todo esto su resultado bastante densa es
una novela de más de tantas páginas y
que incluye más de 250 personajes
esta lista de personajes este desfilar
este entrecruzamiento de personajes
Busca usted hacer un reflejo de la
sociedad de hoy si exactamente Quería
dar la voz como han hecho otros
escritores a lo largo de la historia la
voz a una ciudad entera lanzar una
mirada Cómo se mueve hoy día una ciudad
con toda esa polifonía de Voces que
encierran una polifonía que va
reflejada en distinto lenguajes
dependiendo del del estrato social de
los Héroes de la novela muchas veces el
lenguaje Define al propio personaje y
nos Define a nosotros oímos Hablar a
alguien y ya sabemos mucho de él del
modo en el que se expresa o por en el
que se expresa pero también en esa
ambición polifónica podíamos llamar y
quería abarcar distintos géneros
literarios hay una serie de registros y
las distintas voces como digo que que
aparecen en una ciudad
desde personas de alto nivel social al
más humilde pero también pasando por la
publicidad por la radio por la
televisión por la televisión por los
WhatsApps por todo es ese magma de
lenguajes que hay en una ciudad
contemporánea Hoy día hay varias novelas
al interior de la novela se puede decir
así pero hay una constante que recorre
sur y es el tema del calor el calor
aparece en todas las expresiones en
todos los momentos hay una momento en
donde Guillermo uno de los personajes de
la novela dice tanto calor que bastaría
comprender una cerilla para que todo
ardiera para que el aire ardiera y más
adelante algunas más adelante dice usted
es un calor que disloca los termómetros
esto quiere decir es una imagen o es un
mensaje político más que un mensaje
político Yo diría que es un
estado
natural
que que se produce en determinados
momentos y que distorsionan de alguna
forma la realidad
leyendo a un clásico francés como al ver
que a mí el extranjero
sino acordamos del momento en el que el
protagonista de la novela dispara sobre
un árabe que encuentra en la playa el
calor es absolutamente determinante en
ese momento
está el calor hay una luminosidad
exagerada que trastorna al personaje y
está demostrado
que las altas temperaturas
dislocan trastornan la conducta humana y
como yo lo que pretendía era ahondar un
poco en la piel de
los protagonistas
de la de la novela me parecía que ese
dislocamiento que ese trastorno que
produce el calor Nos podía decir un poco
más Quiénes son en verdad y realmente
Quiénes somos nosotros de eso trata la
novela se abre con con una cita extensa
de Octavio Paz exactamente donde
finalmente a lo que nos combina es
averiguar Quiénes son los otros y yo
creo que cuando sabemos algo más de los
otros sabemos mucho más de nosotros
mismos evidentemente desde las primeras
páginas de Sur nos plantea lo que va a
ser vamos a decir una parte del
recorrido de esa novela hay que decir
que es una serie de personajes que
aparecen a la distancia hay algo que
está sucediendo algo que no se logra ver
es este personaje central que no sabemos
si está acostado si está muerto si está
dormido pero que nadie quiere todo el
mundo se pregunta pero nadie quiere
acercarse a ver qué es lo que sucede hay
algo que le pasa a él que su cuerpo su
boca está invadido por las hormigas Cuál
era el mensaje con esto bueno Esta es
una historia que que Real que me contó
una amiga médico que en un día de un
calor extremo
hubo una llamada al hospital de urgencia
y dijeron que había un hombre en un
descampado en un estado prácticamente
moribundo completamente cubierto de
hormigas
una imagen terrible pero aún más
terrible cuando esta amiga médico me
dice que una compañera suya también
médico le dice creo que va a ser mi
marido Esto ocurrió realmente
y efectivamente la novela exacto y luego
lo reciben y este hombre muere a las
pocas horas y qué había ocurrido Pues
que este hombre lleva una doble vida
por su condición sexual él era
homosexual
pero ante la sociedad Había decidido
esconder su verdadera tendencia se casa
pero finalmente
está
claro y está sufriendo bajo esa máscara
que que sea impuesto y que le ha
impuesto la sociedad en cierto modo y la
imagen me parecía muy muy clara las
hormigas Como animal social estaban
devorando y realmente lo que ocurrió Es
que la sociedad se comió este hombre y
acabó con él acabó con su vida por las
intransigencias por las prevenciones
malsanas y por la censura que muchas
veces nos lleva a autocensurarnos estas
cosas ocurren Esto me lleva otra
pregunta ese personaje es Dionisio
precisamente se casó con la doctora
galán y ambos personajes se conocen en
1975 y cuando ellos se conocen usted
dice lo describe ese año como un año
opresivo y liberador yo le preguntaría
es una referencia concreta a la muerte
de Francisco Franco en España en
noviembre de 1975 Sí exactamente lo lo
ha dicho usted muy bien para un para los
españoles 1975 es un año clave
en la historia como 1936 lo fue con el
inicio de la guerra civil y
el año 75 fue opresor porque todavía
continuaba la mano de la dictadura Y
todavía en septiembre de ese año hubo
sentencias de muerte que se ejecutaron
pero al mismo tiempo había un Halo de
Esperanza a la muerte del dictador a la
muerte de Franco y me pareció que que
una buena definición podía ser si un año
opresivo doloroso pero también lleno de
Esperanza liberador ciertomente hay otra
cosa que recorre surgen permanencia y
son personajes obsesionados con el sexo
porque esta cuestión de usted dibuja lo
decíamos en un principio la sociedad
pero todos los personajes de una u otra
manera tienen que ver precisamente con
el sexo sus obsesión de sus sueños sus
perversiones sus decepciones y sus
deseos y
en algún momento cuando
estaba empezando a escribir la novela
Sur recordé una novela picaresca
española que se titula el cojuelo
y en la cual al inicio de
del relato
el lleva al protagonista al cielo
de Madrid y hace levantar los tejados de
las casas para ver realmente que está
ocurriendo dentro para saber de verdad
quiénes son esas personas
yo en cierto modo es lo que he intentado
hacer y no solo levantar los tejados
sino levantar la tapa de la cabeza y
mirar que que hay dentro lo que no se
manifiesta normalmente lo que está ahí
oculto los el deseos Claro que unas
veces se satisfacen otras veces no pero
que están sobrevolando de un modo de
otro a veces de un modo per a veces de
un modo muy ingenuo muy inocente como en
el caso de algunos adolescentes que hay
en la novela y me parecía que eso es
insordalayable que que si hablamos de
verdad de lo como decía de lo más
recóndito del ser humano la sexualidad
está ahí latente Una última pregunta
Antonio Soler escribió una novela tan
densa tan polifacética implica un gran
esfuerzo me imagino mucho tiempo cuánto
le llevó esto escribió esta novela y
sobre todo en la cabeza idea de una
nueva novela
es difícil contestar exactamente cuánto
tiempo nos lleva a escribir una novela
Porque podríamos medir el el tiempo que
lleva desde poner la primera palabra Al
Punto Final pero realmente uno está
trabajando en la creación de novelas
desde antes está uniendo y conectando
ideas recuerdos sensaciones cosas que
uno Ha oído y de todo ese flujo se va
formando la idea el cuerpo primero en mi
caso mentalmente de la novela antes de
poner la primera palabra pero para
contestar de un modo sucinto desde que
puse la primera palabra hasta el punto
final después de las correcciones
aproximadamente un año
Y sí sí hay otra novela en la cabeza
Claro pues perfecto estamos llegando ya
al final de esta escala en París no me
queda sin agradecerle Antonio Soler
escritor español autor de sud revista
Perdón novela que ha sido traducida
recientemente por ediciones rivadas aquí
en Francia su presencia en nuestros
estudios muchísimas gracias de habernos
acompañado Antonio a ustedes les damos
una nueva cita la próxima semana aquí en
otra escala en París
[Música]
[Aplausos]